okay so I left you guys on a bit of a
cliffhanger in the last video
so I'm gonna make up for that here right
so what ended up happening is once
Ultron arrives on the scene a fight
immediately breaks out between him and
Adam Warlock now this is something that
you don't usually see and that's one of
the things to know for those of you guys
who are new to Marvel Comics Marvel for
the most part kind of keep things
contained in-house and it's something
that people aren't necessarily fans of
but oftentimes what you will see when it
comes to various groups facing off
against various villains is they sort of
keep it to themselves now a lot of
that's just the nature of the comics in
a Spider-Man comic for example you don't
really see him fighting a villain of
Captain America you wouldn't really see
him fighting Red Skull because
Spider-Man largely has his own villains
to fight now that's kind of the downside
of comics because somebody Takes Over
The Run of Spider-Man and it's like well
here we go Peter Parker's gonna fight
the Green Goblin again for like the one
millionth time and it does kind of get
boring after a while and Marvel tries to
solve that that issue with crossovers
which I think is the wrong way to
approach it but the fact remains that
you don't usually see Ultron facing off
against Adam Warlock and what you're
talking about here is a version of ultra
Ron that's just as strong as he ever was
facing off against a guy that he's never
fought before but is well aware of and
that's kind of a cool thing because
again when it comes to these different
superheroes while you may not
necessarily see them fight villains that
don't traditionally belong to them these
villains are aware of who they are and
when it comes to Adam Warlock his
significance exists on a universal level
everybody in the universe knows who Adam
Warlock is at least if they've been
around for a little while again that's
the reason why philavel doesn't really
know because she hasn't been here all
that long but given the cosmic power of
Adam Warlock even if he doesn't have
total control over it he is able to hold
his own against the Phalanx to a degree
but he's not able to hold them off
permanently and that's an important
thing to grasp here is because a lot of
people who are fans of Adam Warlock
would be like no Adam Warlock would
absolutely destroy the Phalanx with very
little effort and under normal
circumstances you would be right if
we're talking about Adam Warlock during
the events of like The Infinity Gauntlet
or Adam Warlock during Infinity war or
Infinity Crusade or you're talking about
him in any of the other stories were
written out there yeah I mean he would
win this blindfolded but one of the
things you to remember is this is Adam
Warlock freshly back right so his powers
haven't fully coalesced but at the same
time he doesn't fully know who he is or
what he's capable of so it's not Adam
Warlock at 100 and so him going against
the Phalanx and being able to kind of
hold his own but also struggling is one
a testament to the power of the Phalanx
but two also shows how weakened Adam
Warlock is in this situation and so what
ends up happening here is when he does
go against Ultron Ultron does get the
upper hand on him now you do have fight
level with moon dragon trying to race
her out of there as fast as they can but
ultimately she ends up harassing and so
beseeching the high evolutionary and
just being like we have to find a way at
it here like we have to get out of here
as fast as we can at the end of the day
it's all they really can do Adam Warlock
kind of keeps going through these energy
fluxes right where he has these sort of
energy-based epileptic seizures if you
want to call them that and where
philavel does show up this is one of the
most badass moments for a character this
is one of the reasons why I tell people
final Val is someone who slept on and
when the time comes where she gets put
in the MCU like she's gonna blow the
doors off right you haven't seen
anything from anybody in the MCU when it
comes to like hand-to-hand conflict
Wanda Vectra Monica Rambo Captain
America none of those guys have anything
on fire level because when she comes in
here she starts taking it to the Phalanx
and literally just hacking them to
Pieces but here's the downside to this
while she is just super amped up and she
is able to hold her own Adam Warlock
communicates with the high evolutionary
and the high evolutionary tells him
final level can buy us time but the
reality here is she's fighting blood
Lester she's not fighting intelligently
she's not fighting cleanly she's
fighting emotionally and as a result of
that she's going to make a mistake and
when that happens that will give Ultron
and the Phalanx the one opening they
need to get the upper hand on her and to
either kill her or capture her and turn
her into a select the only option we
have here is to get out as fast as we
can but what the high evolutionary
reveals is it is kind of a safety
measure what he had done was basically
build a bomb inside of a sun inside of
the local star and when that happens he
basically ends up detonating it and it
literally destroys the entire Sun along
with a whole star system now it does
give High evolutionary and those guys
the chance to get out of there but it
destroys all the existing Phalanx in
that area along with Ultron now that's
not the last time we're gonna see him
don't worry Ultron didn't go out with
the death of a star it would be the
least interesting ending to Ultron ever
so don't worry it's not the last time we
see him but what we end up doing here is
switching over to Ron and the accuser
and basically ravenous now ravenous is
the one who leads the forces of the
annihilation wave to a lot to offer a
little more explanation here because I
know I was a little scant on providing
information to you guys over the course
of like everything that was going on so
when annihilus made his invasion of the
main Marvel Universe during Annihilation
one of the things that happened here is
he tasked ravenous with tracking down
those individuals that had the ability
to tap into the end of the power Cosmic
Galactus Silver Surfer and those guys
the nature of the annihilation wave was
not just a giant army of bugs I mean it
was to a degree but you basically had
generals right those individuals who are
more powerful than the this Army of a
trillion bucks they could basically lead
them carry out their orders different
things like that but ravenous was
powerful enough to overcome the Silver
Surfer and Galactus so this guy's no
small threat now one thing to understand
he did have the entire backing of the
annihilation wave at his disposal so
that's one of the ways in which he was
able to get it done but the truth about
this is that Ron and the accuser showing
up here is done for a very particular
reason because when he arrives it's
actually to gain access to the Citadel
not even to really make a deal with
ravenous he simply says he's there to do
that but he literally lies his ass off
he's like oh I'm here to broker a deal
I'm here to for us to kind of join
forces create a coalition and to
basically find a way to tear down the
fan links but the reality here is that
ravenous of the annihilation wave have
no respect for the cree and if they had
it their way they would eradicate the
entirety of the creep what you have here
is kind of a stalemate you have
basically the entire Cree race led by
the Supreme intelligence which are
ridiculously powerful standing against
ravenous and what's left of the
annihilation wave if the annihilation
wave decided to attack the cree it would
basically lead to the destruction of
both races right vice versa if a Cree
decided to attack the annihilation wave
they would basically end up getting
annihilated right it would destroy all
of their forces and so where you
initially have ravenous who's like there
will be no truce and initially goes
against and tries to find a way to
destroy Ron and the accuser you
basically end up having wraith that
makes his move now wraith is a character
that we really haven't talked about too
much in Marvel Comics and a lot of
that's because he's very much a fringe
character he does have his Origins that
kind of predate the events of
annihilation and Annihilation Conquest
but this is the first time when you
really see any meaningful appearance of
his character the reality here is he's
not that important to the overall Marvel
landscape and he's really not even
important to Annihilation Conquest he's
only really important in this moment but
he is immensely powerful so when it
comes to wraith the idea behind his
character is that he is a guy or at
least was a Cree Who as a child was
sucked into a kind of Wormhole after his
family was slaughtered and basically
encountered a group called The nameless
now the nameless as they were presented
to us by Dan Abner were basically Cree
who were sucked in the worm hole as well
but he ended up having these kind of
parasites that basically infected his
body and they operate something akin to
the Venom symbiote right where they're
not that dissimilar the overall gist
behind this is that because of the
parasites the Exelon that basically
infect him the way this works is one
he's got a healing factor that Rivals
Deadpool and depending on the story
actually expands Beyond it right like
his healing factor is insane he can heal
from virtually anything instantaneously
as long as a being is not of sufficient
power to eradicate him on the spot he
can survive from virtually any sort of
damage but the the X on themselves of
these parasites also provide kind of uh
of the ability to metamorph right so in
the same way that like Carnage as a
symbiote can turn his arms into like
axes and things like that that wraith
can more or less do the same thing but
because of these parasites within him he
is by all standards of measurement
Immortal right again so long as some
being out there of sufficient power
can't destroy him then he'll never
really be destroyed the reality is that
In This Moment In Time the only reason
why he matters and really the only
reason why we're been talking about him
is because using his capabilities he
basically subdues ravenous and they kind
of is the equivalent of having like a
gun in his head right like anybody do
anything and we shoot that's really kind
of how it is but what it does is it
keeps the forces of the annihilation
wave at Bay and it allows Ron and the
accuser to access the quote-unquote
weapon of the Creed the Ultimate Weapon
of the cree we'll find out exactly what
that is at a future point in time but
what we end up doing here is basically
switching over to the Guardians of the
Galaxy right now again like we talked
about in the last video they're not
technically the guardians but they more
or less are the team is forming over the
course of the story right like Dan Abner
it's like here's a bunch of guys who
were banded together for a singular
cause some of them aren't going to make
it and the ones who are left they're
going to become the Guardians of the
Galaxy that's basically how this is
working right now again their goal is to
plant bombs throughout the entirety of
the Babel's fire in order to detonate it
but in the midst of all this they're met
by the arrival of blastar who is
basically turned into one of the select
of the fan links because of how powerful
he is along with Ultron himself now of
course basically blastar kills some of
the members who don't quite make it to
become Guardians to the Galaxy and Peter
Quill is ultimately subdued and met by
the arrival of Ultron so of course where
the rest of the members are able to make
their escape Peter's taken prisoner
inevitably he's going to experience
torture here now this is where we would
normally end the video and we would end
it in some super amped up way making up
for the fact that I left you guys on a
massive Cliffhanger in the last video
what we end up doing here is picking up
with Ultron as he as really you kind of
have the torturing process going on with
Peter Quill now ultron's initial
response here to these guys right to the
fan lengths who are taking it to Peter
is why are you physically torturing him
we need what's in his head we don't need
what's in his body right we don't need
that to happen and so the results of
this is Ultron tries to use the power of
the fan lengths basically technological
telepathy to read them on and to scan
the mind of Peter Quill now the benefit
to this is that mantis is actually
keeping the mind of Peter protected so
that Ultron can't read the mind of Peter
and learn anything about the Insurgency
that's taking place on the the cree
Planet holla as well as what the
ultimate plans are for the planet itself
right for the Babel spire and so Peter
Quill just kind of undergoing this form
of torture Ultron comes to this
realization that because of the fact
that he can't read the mind of Peter
Quill that instead he is going to have
to physically break him right he's going
to have to just inflict such Horrors on
him that Peter Quill has gonna really
have no choice but to relent if for no
other reason than to make the pain stop
and so what this does is this jumps back
to Adam Warlock philavel and the high
evolutionary now Adam Warlock again
because of the nature of his Cosmic
powers and so on is able to perform or
create a kind of sphere that himself and
high evolutionary and phylavel are able
to escape in but again his powers are a
little kind of finicky here right
they're not working perfectly so while
it is seemingly enough to allow them to
basically transport the reality here is
that Adam warlock's powers are
constantly in a state of flux and so
what this means is that as they approach
the planet holla then ultimately his
powers flake out and when that happens
they're just barely able to make it to
holla itself now jumping back to Ron in
the accuser the Revelation that he
provides here in terms of the source of
power that the cree have is basically
their centuries now this is kind of a
crazy thing and it's in initially it
seems kind of dumb and ravenous even
calls it right off the bat because if
you guys remember at the beginning of
annihilation Conquest the first thing to
be taken over by the Phalanx were the
centuries of the cree now for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with this
the crease centuries are basically just
these giant robots that the cree makes
to carry out their own campaigns it's
one of the reasons why the cree have
been such a formidable Force throughout
the entirety of the universe because
over the years and when I say years I
mean like the millions of years that
their race has been around if not
potentially billions that what you have
were them developing centuries which
were these supremely powerful robots
that would normally go in and either
accompany Cree soldiers or just fight
the battle and Cree soldier's stead
right so that you know the crew don't
have to worry about losing their own but
the centuries were immensely powerful in
Marvel Comics when the centuries first
popped up they were overpowering Earth
superheroes so that's kind of how all
these things exist they're exceedingly
capable but ravenous calls it right off
the bat it's like this is your grand
plan right like literally the centuries
were the first thing the Phalanx took
over the robots you're gonna set an army
of robots against an army that can take
over robots this is your grand plan if
you're not the dumbest person that I've
ever met in my entire life then I don't
know what you are right and that's when
Ronin makes his Revelation and say no
these are Cree uh Cree centuries sure
and they are robots the difference here
is that I brought a woman with me fax a
Gore right this girl can Shield these
robots from the influence of the Phalanx
we can literally send these immensely
powerful robots in and the Phalanx will
never be able to take them over the
Phalanx will never be able to conquer
them so long as we maintain that control
we now have an expansion to our army now
one thing I want to make make you guys
aware of any one of these centuries is
more than enough for the forces of
ravenous and his Annihilation wave and
so at this point we jump back to Adam
Warlock and we jump back to phylavel now
again one of the things that had
happened here is the high evolutionary
had basically stated that at the request
of the Supreme intelligence he had
devised a way to create perfect Creed
right and to essentially take these
these new Cree essentially turn them
into kind of uh empty vessels if you
want to call them that and take the
consciousness of an existing cree and
put them into the body of a new Creed
right literally bioengineer beams of
immense power so it's like if I created
a version of you that could bench press
2 000 pounds but that version of you had
no consciousness and then I could take
your brain and put it in the body of
that version of yourself that can now
bench press two thousand pounds that's
what we're talking about here right like
a transference of Consciousness and this
in turn would allow the cree to expand
its capabilities and to move on what the
high evolutionary reveals here to Adam
Warlock into Phila valve is it did
exactly that the Supreme intelligence
followed the instructions of the the
high evolutionary down to a t before its
presumed destruction during Annihilation
then it followed everything exactly as
it was supposed to what file Lavelle and
Adam Warlock are looking at here in this
giant hallway full of all these vessels
are these new Cree bodies that are just
waiting to be inhabited But ultimately
in the midst of this conversation the
Phalanx emerge but when Adam Warlock
asked the question High evolutionary why
are those guys here the response of the
high evolutionary is yeah about them
they got here first and they made me an
offer I'm sorry Adam Warlock and the
high evolutionary turns against Adam
Warlock and sides with Ultron and the
phalanes with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end another
Cliffhanger right thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace